we have a lot of companies exposed to
Northeastern natural gas eqt Range
Resources Cabot which one is in the
worst spot right now with Maddie gasps
about one dollar well I would say when
we think about all four players and
given the region's that they are exposed
to all of them have their pluses and
minuses well give you an example range
resources in 2q realized pricing was 295
/ M that was the highest of the four but
because of their hedged book that added
a dollar so really the unrealized the
unhedged realized price was around a
buck 95 now for the rest of 2015 they
are eighty five percent hedged which
makes them the highest of the four of
the three Cabot's policy is to be
roughly twenty-five percent to
seventy-five percent hedged southwestern
is roughly forty percent hedged now it's
not so much their hedge book but also
their cash costs and when you think
about the average for all for their cash
costs are right around a dollar per m so
even with realizations being low and the
basis differentials being wide they're
still in a better position relative to
other players outside the play when we
take a look at that cash unit cost but
what happens when the hedges first of
all when did the hedges roll off is a
2016 when that comes to so 2015 these
hedges will roll off in 2016 some are
hedged for example range is hedged 4
2016 roughly about half of their output
for 2016 the others less so so 2016
there will be some impact if the the
basis differentials remain wide so one
dollar cash costs I mean that kind of
blows my mind a little bit how are costs
solo for the utica and marcellus it's a
much more prolific area and it's a wider
area and these these companies have
cracked the code for this pro
fick region the marcellus and now the
Utica the Utica is a little behind the
cost curve relative to the Marcellus
it's a newer more recent play for
example EQT did a successful test well
at roughly 30 million dollars now
granted 30 million dollars is
significant that should come on down
over the course of the next couple of
tests wells their hope is to get it down
to 12 and a half million